she invested in herself in something she
really loved that appreciated
in value innovation is disruption
and so whenever you have a tesla or
somebody that's trying to change the
world
you're going to piss somebody off i
don't want to work out today
i don't want to go for a walk i don't
want to start investing there's always a
reason not to do
something and it's your enemy
[Music]
it's always this you talk about saving
money and not spending any money
and that has to be part of your protocol
how you live your life and you have to
invest
not just save i've talked about this
dozens of times
but that means you can't buy anything
you're always taking a hundred bucks a
week which is what i say you should do
and investing it over the long period
because the markets give you somewhere
between a six and eight percent return
over long periods of time yes they go up
and down
but the whole idea i've been talking
about is
taking a portion of your salary let's
say you only make 56
000 a year the average salary and you
take a hundred bucks a week
and you start investing it not saving it
in a savings account because that
doesn't pay any interest anymore but
putting it into the stock market
and letting it grow over 30 40 years
if you do that and you have that
discipline you'll end up
a millionaire in your 60s where you
really need to have some money
to retire with as much as a million and
a half dollars so i think that's a
pretty pragmatic strategy where did i
learn that
from my mother georgette but the
question i'm always getting is
what about living what about spending on
things that you love what about
clothes what about fashion what about
all the things
that i want to buy do i do i have to
just
go spartan i can't buy any of that stuff
not true
i want you to have a different mindset
when you purchase
things for yourself and let me give it
to you in a lesson that i learned from
my own mother
and i've told this story countless of
times countless times countless times
my mother georgette was a working girl
in her 20s she worked at a factory owned
by her father that made
children's winter clothing she would
save 20 percent
of her salary each week and invest it
but it's not all she did with it she
loved fashion too
she loved clothing she liked to buy
things for herself
but she had a different mindset about it
she told me years later and this really
changed the way i think about buying
stuff
that she would save a whole year just to
buy
one jacket instead of buying a whole ton
of cheap stuff
that she would throw out a year later
and maybe not even wear
she would save up for one thing that she
really wanted
she loved chanel so when it came to
clothing
she loved chanel jackets they cost a
fortune back then
but they were very high quality and they
look beautiful and her thinking was they
last forever in your wardrobe
chanel never goes out of style now
talking
about style and talking about fashion
in georgette's mind was it really is who
you are you're presenting yourself to
the world and you want to look good you
want to feel good about yourself
the reason i tell you that story and why
it's so powerful to me
is years later when she passed away
and i became the executive for her
estate
i started getting phone calls from all
the women in my extended family saying
what happened to georgette chanel
jackets
what do you mean what happened to them
they're hanging up
in the wardrobe well i would like one of
them
in fact i'd like them all and i began to
realize that these jackets
were classics all the women were
fighting over them they all wanted the
chanel jackets why they were worth more
today than they were 30 years ago
because they were one of a kind in some
cases classic chanels
how brilliant georgette was how genius
that was
she invested in herself in something she
really loved that appreciated in
value that's what i'm talking about i
want you to start thinking that way
now let's go back and listen to ralph
lauren
a guy that understands style and
investing listen to what he said years
ago
you'll appreciate this
is
you get it right he's talking about how
you want to present yourself to the
world
so my whole theory about
fashion is it's about you it's how you
want to present yourself so you have two
options you can buy a whole bunch of
crap you don't wear all the time
cheap clothing a lot of people go that
way or you can start investing in pieces
that are going to appreciate
in style that really mean something to
you now i'm dressed up in a suit today
the one you see me in all the time why
do i dress in this black suit well it's
my uniform
years ago a very savvy wardrobe director
when we were shooting shark tank over 10
years ago said
kevin you look good in a black suit
white shirt black tie
maybe a little classic kutramal like a
tie pin
make it a standard and you'll never have
to shoot outtakes because when you shoot
shark tank and you change your outfit
at the end of that shooting day you have
to do outtakes because those shows are
put together they're stitched together
you might shoot one deal on a tuesday
and another deal on a friday
and they end up in the same show but if
you change your clothing
it's harder for the editors and you've
got to do a lot more post-production
work
by having the standard uniform i wear i
avoid all that wasted time
great lesson for me but it also became
sort of my signature look in business
it's crisp it's easy so i invested in
myself
and my look i have 25 of these jackets
25 pants 25 tapes 25 black ties
25 handmade shirts it's an investment
it's not junk it's very valuable to me
you should think about your clothing
that way too think the way georgette did
buy one thing you really love that you
know you're going to wear
but it's not just clothing okay i want
to talk about another asset class let's
take for example watches everybody knows
i collect watches
this is another situation where you can
buy something for yourself
love it because you love the style of it
and then over time during your life it
appreciates
in value can it be material appreciation
oh yeah now i'm wearing today a rolex
steel
white face daytona an entry level watch
not excessively expensive but
you know a stylish piece from rolex now
i have many different brands and i'm not
endorsing rolex
one over another i love grand seiko i
love patek i love
eddie more piquet i love all kinds mings
micro brands vacheron you name it i have
these watches in my collection for a
reason i love to collect them but i also
am investing
i'm thinking long term now how much are
watches worth over time
i'm going to give you an extreme example
i want you to watch this video about
a daytona which is why i wore this one
today bought in the 70s for just around
400 bucks
or under 500 anyways and then what is it
worth today
you might get a real kick out of this
now this is an extreme example but i
want to point out to you the idea
of investing in yourself in pieces you
love
that can appreciate over time i brought
in a rolex watch that
i had purchased while i was in the
military
i flew on air america airlines
and continental airlines and i noticed
that most of the pilots that were
flying those aircraft wore rolex watches
and i was intrigued by them i always
wanted to purchase them but they were
very expensive later when i was
transferred to another base
i did some scuba diving and i knew that
the rolex watch was good for scuba
diving
i found this particular watch
where i could afford it and i never used
it i looked at it and i said you know
this is really too nice to take down in
a
salty water i just kept it and this
particular model being marked oyster
is extremely extremely rare basically
it's a new old stock watch
nowhere on it the original foil sticker
on the back of it
and the fact that we have all this
complete documentation here also
maybe one of the very few in the whole
world that still was never worn
your watch at auction today
500 to 700 thousand dollars
now how crazy is that
400 and change to 700 000 during a man's
lifetime
yes it can happen that's an extreme
example but my point is these watches to
appreciate
in fact paul newman's you heard
reference to in that video sold for 17.5
million
your watch may not do that but the point
is over time a beautiful time
piece that you love that you invested in
for yourself
goes up in value i'll give you another
example i love guitars
now here's a guitar um
this is it's a one of a kind guitar
it was made for me uh by the guys at
benji lock one of my shark tank
companies it's a beautiful piece
ec 401 with this special paint mr
wonderful screaming at you i love that
but i also love to play it now this is
another excuse for me just to mess
around and i love doing it but i'm
trying to make a point about another
asset class
guitars they're beautiful they're fun
you can play them you can learn how to
play them
you know just messing around but that's
the whole idea
i love the guitar is this guitar going
to be worth more 20 years from now
i think it will be now let me give you
an example those of you that love
guitars know
what a gibson les paul is it's a classic
guitar and rock and roll
you've seen it played by some of the
biggest rockers of all time
designed by a guy named les paul well
les paul recently passed away
he used to play at a jazz club called
the iridium in new york
i loved him i loved all he did in that
he was a grammy winner as well not only
for music but also for inventions around
music
multi-track recorders that kind of thing
les paul's a legend for that
i went to seem at the radium and i
brought my les paul
to les paul to ask les paul to sign my
les paul
and he did here he is signing it now
what do you think that guitar is worth
today not only do i still
play it i love to have it but it's
signed by less to me
my whole point is to talk about
investing in yourself
and thinking wisely about how you spend
your money you don't have to be spartan
you don't have to starve yourself from
the joys of life
you have to think pragmatically buy less
stuff
but when you buy stuff make it good
stuff make it investable stuff
whether it be a watch whether it be a
guitar
even something like a ballpoint pen
yeah you can spend 29 cents on a pen and
throw it away or you can buy
a collectible piece like this one a mole
blah
they only make so many of them and over
time they appreciate in value
and they're wonderful to have this is a
collectible
it's it's a design around egyptian
hieroglyphics it's
etched on the body of the pen now you
may say that's triton stupid i don't
think so
it's stylish i love to use it it's
functional pragmatic
and it's appreciating in value you know
i gift
pens to people in business very rare
pens sometimes
to celebrate a deal they really
appreciate it and when they look back
five years later when that
pen has gone out of production it's
enhanced in value dramatically
i want you to think that way buy less
stuff
but buy good stuff that means something
to you
that too my friends is investing in the
future
hi kevin my question is what should i do
with the 21 000 in my bank account
i'm only 20 and i have 21 000 because of
a parent passing away when i was younger
and i was wondering if you had any
thoughts on how i should invest it and
grow it so that i have a nice size
savings account after college
also what's your opinion on insurance
investors
the rates vary but you can't lose money
thanks for your time and have a great
day
yeah first of all i'm very sad to hear
about the passing of your parents at
such a young age
that's sad however i think you're really
thinking ahead that's very smart 20 21
000
you want to put that to work i prefer
these days using etfs
exchange traded funds and here's why
these days most online brokers
will let you set up an account no fees
which is fantastic because we really
want to reduce our fees if we can
so you set up one of those and then you
wire in the 21 000
and if you're you know you're young
you're 21 so generally speaking
the older you get the more you want to
put in more conservative investments
like fixed income like bonds something
like that
or these you know these guaranteed
certificates of deposit which aren't
great in my view because you're only
making about two percent but that's not
bad if you're just saving money
but you can get etfs that are basically
a basket of very short-term government
bonds that yield about 1.9 to 2.1
percent
so the key is all of these services
provide you with information about which
etfs to buy i like etfs they're
transparent
they're low fee they're very liquid you
can buy and sell them so i would buy
some you know something like the spy
which is the entire market
it's very inexpensive you get the whole
you know
standard and poor's 500 stocks that make
up the largest market cap companies in
the world basically
and then maybe you get 50 in that and
then
another um 40 in
a couple of etfs that are just short
duration government bonds and short
duration corporate credits again these
are available
and you i always say ask an advisor
because you're going to get one for free
on these online services you can just
just text them and they'll give you
information say look i want to be sort
of
50 in equities in expensive etfs
and maybe a 40 in
uh short duration government bonds and
short-turation corporate debt
investment grade that's triple b and
then 10 cash and most of these provide a
cash account too
which has yield so then all the money is
going to work it'll be volatile stocks
will go up and down but over time
because emily you're so young
i think you probably you know on average
from the past you're going to make six
seven percent a year on average on the
equities and maybe two or three percent
on the debt
and it'll grow and it'll be ready for
you when you retire and don't forget to
add to it
you got to add to it take 10 of your
salary is what i always say
thank you for that one let's go to our
next question thanks mr wonderful for
taking my question
the greatest technical innovations have
usually been met with fierce opposition
from large corporate competitive
interests
innovators like nikola tesla come to
mind what is your advice to innovators
on how to confront or avoid similar
opposition
so innovation is disruption and so
whenever you have
a tesla or somebody that's trying to
change the world
going all electric cars you're going to
piss somebody off
because maybe you're building gas-driven
cars or maybe you're already existing
industry
disruption is always met with resistance
that always happens but that's how we
advance
i mean it's really great when things
keep moving forward
and i think i own a tesla now i was very
skeptical my son works at tesla he's an
intern there
so he's beginning to learn his craft and
he's very interested in how the future
is going to look as you sound like you
are
my advice to people that want to be
mavericks
is put your blinders on focus on what
you want to achieve and don't listen to
all the noise
that noise is horrific and just really
really bad
and it's always going to be eating at
you but you've got to stay focused on
the goal
i was taught that years ago by a mentor
and it's absolutely
true stay focused don't let distractors
bother you don't let them get you down
and invariably
you're going to be kicked to the ground
as a maverick or an entrepreneur or
anybody that's trying to achieve their
own freedom
but you got to get up and keep going
that's my advice great question though i
like that a lot
these are very thoughtful questions it's
terrific let's see what we got next
hello mr wonderful my name is justin and
i'm 26 years old
one year ago i started a construction
and development company with no loans or
investors
so far has gone very well and just in
the last six months we have had 1.5
million dollars in revenue
with well over 200 000 in net profit
after paying myself
we have incredible growth slotted for
next year based on signed contracts
my issue is i'm feeling guilty paying
myself so early in the company life
after hearing the sharks and other
entrepreneurs stories
i just want your opinion on when it is
okay to start giving yourself a salary
thanks mr wonderful justin you're a rock
star my friend
good for you that's absolutely
spectacular that's what it takes the
guts to get out there and start i'm
really excited for you
now look i got some advice here okay
number one there's nothing wrong with
paying yourself particularly
from what i'm listening to you can
afford it but the key to that
is you're taking it out of the company
and investing it in something else
that's completely different
that justin is the concept of
diversification so you put it into an
etf or you put it into the stock market
you put it into bonds
but it has nothing to do with your
construction business because what you
find in life is what you get too
concentrated and you leave all the money
in the business
and something happens and believe me in
life people happens
you're wiped out you don't want that to
happen you're starting your
diversification now so let's say you
pull out 50 000
basically have to live off it but if you
could keep 10
or 15 of what you're taking out and
invest it in something completely
different like a portfolio of stocks and
bonds
that's how you get wealthy long term but
i love that entrepreneurial spirit you
are a
rock star absolutely fantastic
clearly you're very focused on what
you're doing and many others can learn
from what justin just said
i mean he's focused on business and he
did it without anybody else's cash you
100 of your business
spectacular you know it makes me feel
great to hear that kind of thing and for
all of the others of you are listening
you got to be a justin if you really
have that entrepreneurial spirit in your
heart you go and become a justin
absolutely great i love that one thank
you justin terrific
[Music]
[Applause]
a brief musical interlude
get much
i hope you get what you need with mr
wonderful because i'm answering
questions
let's go to gavin here hey mr wonderful
i'm 16 years old and i'm an aspiring
entrepreneur and i think i have a good
idea for a tech startup but the problem
is that i don't know how to code
i'm afraid that the need to hire
developers will push away
all potential investors should i take
the time to learn
code over the next couple years or
should i go ahead and start anyways
thank you any response would be
appreciated gavin
you don't have to be a coder to be an
entrepreneur the key is you've got to
find coders are going to work with you
and for you
you're doing a startup find a great
coder because look it's an extreme
talent
you know if you're good at coding you're
good at coding if you're good as an
entrepreneur good as a manager you're
good at that
that sounds like what you are so you
have a vision for a business
you find a great coder to lead the team
and you give that person that man or
woman some equity
they become effectively your partner if
they have a they believe in your vision
that's how all the great companies were
started that's how steve jobs started
apple
think about it found a fantastic
engineer and worked with them the two of
them built that business to the largest
company on earth today
look there's nothing wrong with with not
being a coder and you're probably not
going to be able to
it's kind of like a half something you
were born with
you really have to have an unusual mind
to be a great coder that's what i've
learned
but i've hired hundreds of coders in my
day at the learning company we used to
create
software i was a marketing person and
i had to have coders to make breeder
rabbits carmen san diego's and products
like that
you have to understand what you're good
at and focus on that and i think it
sounds like you're going to be terrific
as a manager i want to talk about
everybody's future
the scariest thing for me for anybody
is to end up at the age of 65 with
nothing in the bank in other words no
investment strategy
no retirement fund nothing and you know
the truth is not everybody knows how to
build a long-term diversified portfolio
and i totally get that
you know i was really stunned during the
whole pandemic thing in march and april
when i found out when we did the whole
ppp
payroll loan thing how many of the
people in my organization my employees
and other supply chain entities
that i work with you know all those
people in their 20s and 30s
nothing put aside for the future that
is scary so let's talk about that
because i don't want that to be you
you know at the end of the day you've
really got to think about your future
because
i think no one else is going to do it
for you everybody loves to procrastinate
i don't want to work out today
i don't want to go for a walk i don't
want to start investing there's always a
reason not to do
something and it's your enemy when it
comes to investing
you really want to get over that quickly
because you need the time
value of money to be on your side so
don't procrastinate
start investing find a way to get
discipline put some aside every week
and let it grow for you you're not doing
it for somebody else you're doing it for
you
so when you end up in your 60s you have
something set aside
when people say when should i start
investing my answer is always the same
now now is the time why
because it takes time usually many many
years for investments to grow
and to build your wealth so you've got
to have a long-term strategy
investing can feel really overwhelming
especially when it's
your first time if you've never done
this before it can be scary
ideally you would have started yesterday
but there's no point in dwelling on the
past
let's get started today the most
important step
in the process is to make a commitment
to yourself
and your own future more than a hundred
million americans
don't have any investment accounts
that's crazy that's one third of the
population doing
nothing for retirement doing nothing to
grow their wealth
huge problem you don't want to be one of
them if you start now
you can give your investments more time
and really start to grow your money
think about this
if you invest a hundred dollars a week
every week
not just saving but investing assuming
markets generate growth similar to the
past
30 40 years which has been roughly
around 8 percent
and you invested in a diversified
portfolio
and reinvested your dividends you could
have a million and a half bucks
in the bank in 40 years with just a
hundred dollars a week
is that too hard to do the longer you
wait
the less you will have in retirement so
it's best you get started
right now let's talk about the challenge
of doing it
it's easier than it's ever been before
why because a lot of technology exists
to help you out
it's easier than before because you
don't need to know a lot about
investing to be an investor too many
people seem afraid to invest because
they don't feel like
experts that's why i decided to create
bean stocks
to create an app that does almost all
the investing
for you all of it using your phone and
the beanstalk application
it's really really easy and it costs
only five
dollars a month now here's how it works
step one download beanstalks onto your
phone
or click on the first link in the
description below to get started
step two in the app you'll answer some
basic questions
about your financial goals and risk
tolerance
levels and how much you'd like to invest
to start
and how much automatically each week or
each month
you want to set up the app will then let
you connect your bank account
it's safe and secure and then confirm
how much you want to invest today
the minimum amount is a hundred dollars
and you decide after that how much you
want to set up
as an automatic recurring investment
although there's no minimum for the
reoccurring investment i recommend you
take it
seriously and commit a recurring
investment remember it's for you
it's your future step four once you've
done
steps one two and three and approve the
proposed portfolio for you
you're all set you can now let the
investing happen
once your money gets deposited we invest
it for you in a diversified portfolio
that's right for you based on your
profile
i have a team of experienced investment
professionals that carefully
craft and monitor the portfolios they
work hard on this so you don't have to
they're the experts and as the
investments earn dividend income
the cash is also invested for you that's
what it's all about
long term that's great so there's really
no excuse for not starting today
you don't need to know a lot about
investing to be an investor
all you need is a phone the beanstalks
app
and a bank account that's what you need
a phone the app and a bank account
download beanstalks b-e-a-n-s-t-o-x
it's all in the app stores i mean how
easy is that
so you might ask why start now after the
market's gone up here's what i tell them
and i've learned this the hard way
you can't time the market sometimes the
entire year's return comes in just a few
days and if you're not invested
in those days you miss out you have to
get used to volatility the market going
up and down
but don't try and time it nobody gets
that right
remember when the pandemic started
people panicked and markets dropped
some people thought their investments
were doomed but what actually happened
the market came back as they've done
after every major drop in history
am i predicting what will happen
tomorrow no absolutely not
why because nobody knows i don't have a
crystal ball and either do other
investors
and financial advisors out there the
most important thing to remember
is that investing is a long term game
when i started putting money in the
markets i'd obsessively check my
portfolio
every hour until the closing bell rang
what a waste of time
energy insanity if you want your money
to grow you have to be in the markets
consistently over time volatility
corrections and bear markets
are all to be expected if you look back
at historical market data
over the past few decades you'll see
that the line isn't straight but
overall it does trend upwards
investments in health care have done
really well in recent months but high
investment returns for some securities
have been on just a couple of trading
days the key here is patience is a
virtue in the investing world
you're not getting any younger let's
face it do i really need to start
investing now you might ask yourself
can i wait a year until i make more
money
your 20s and 30s are prime earning years
make the most out of them and the money
you're bringing in now
so you can enjoy your life later it's
going to be a lot harder to put in
extra hours at the office or start a
side gig when you're my age and you
don't want to have to do that
you want a long-term plan we're talking
about it right now prioritize your
finances
when you're young and you'll get ahead
of the game why is this important
let's talk about it savings versus
investing
and the time value of money if you start
putting away a hundred dollars a week as
we talked about earlier
and you just saved that money in your
bank account assuming historical simple
savings rates
in forty years you will have accumulated
approximately
two hundred and eight thousand dollars
now let's talk about
investing that money that sounds like a
lot
but if you invest that money and those
are invested in the markets where the
gains are eight percent a year
have been historically an annualized
return of eight percent
think about this in 40 years you will
have accumulated over a million and a
half bucks
that's why it's important to start now
put your money to work for you
so when it comes to long-term planning
now is the time to do it
i hope you've enjoyed this fireside chat
today because i'm hoping it gets you
past procrastinating
and you start thinking about yourself
and your own future and you
find the discipline to put at least a
hundred dollars a week aside
you know you can do it you really can
there's something you don't need to buy
instead of buying it invest in yourself
invest in yourself for the long term if
you like that video
wait till you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe